So I want to make three
points about the theme
of evaluating teaching
in a research university.
It's really important,
it's really hard,
and it takes collaboration.
So I'm going to take each
one of these in turn.
On the point about it
being really important.
One of our graduate school
of education faculty members
who does research on teaching
effectiveness in the K-12
sphere was corresponding
with me and others recently
and noted that when you
compare student achievement
gains between schools
or between teachers
within a particular school,
the difference between teachers
within a particular school
is two to four times
greater than between schools.
What that means is that teaching
effectiveness, more than school
culture, is really what we
should pay attention to.
And the way he thought about
the implications for higher Ed,
given that research
in K-12, is that,
if we care at Harvard,
not just about bringing
in the smartest and
the best students,
who are going to do great.
They're just going to
do great because they're
so great when they come in.
If we care about the
so-called value added,
then there may be
no other issue that
is important as evaluating
teaching and teaching skills.
So the second point is
coming back to those issues
around that I mentioned about
these lunches and dinners,
putting down the
foundation for what
the theme of the
conference would be.
What we heard here in
the past couple of years
in particularly the faculty get
togethers, always, every one
of these discussions,
there would
be a moment where somebody
would say, how do we know?
How do we know what we're doing
or whether if we try things
it's any good?
How do we understand whether
what we're doing matters?
And so that question of
evaluating what works
and what doesn't is really
important and crucial
to the faculty who are
coming to these discussions.
And then there's a
second point about it
that I think is really
important, which is evaluation
makes people vulnerable.
It's hard to be
evaluated for anybody.
That's human nature.
It's hard to be evaluated.
And so what we heard in these
discussions among faculty
also is the incredible
care that they
have for teaching, and
wanting to do well,
and the vulnerability
that they feel
over course
evaluations, evaluation,
the structure of the university
and how we incentivize teaching
or don't incentivize teaching.
I want to just say, at these
dinners, there were tears.
They were there was intense
moments because it really
matters to people.
So that's point one, importance.
Point two, it's hard.
Thanks to the amazing team
of archives at the Harvard
University Library, we found
out that people at Harvard
have been thinking about these
same issues for a long time,
at least since 1874.
In 1874, 1875 annual report of
the president to the overseers,
there were
suggestions about ways
to improve teaching
so that, quote,
even the most
indifferent student
will find it
desirable to attend.
And so that these
two, quote, banes,
the banes being
absenteeism in body or mind
and the second one
being cramming,
will become less prevalent.
In 1902, a committee on
improving instruction
surveyed all faculty
and all students.
And their responses are
in these paper volumes
that are just beautiful.
There's these giant,
yellowed, rough
edged volumes that
exist in our libraries,
and you can go
through and you can
look at these handwritten
comments that students wrote
and instructors wrote.
And the themes are
really the same.
The language is
really different.
You know, there was there
was a Department of Hygiene,
Department of Mineralogy.
Those departments don't exist,
and the students would say--
I've got this one
quote that I liked--
my style was often
criticized as stiff,
and justly so, but when one
stock of interesting themes is
gone, one cannot
help being stiff.
I don't think that's the way
a student would talk now,
but they might
mean the same thing
when they talk about something
that came up in a classroom.
In the report-- and
the report was authored
by a group of
faculty, one of whom
was Lowell before he was
president of Harvard.
It brought up issues like the
average amount of studying
was discreditably small.
Problems with large
lecture courses,
but that they were here to stay.
Large lecture courses
have problems,
but they're here to stay.
They suggested the use of
frequent quizzes, which we now
know is a really important
for teaching and learning.
They talked about
the bifurcation
of students who are either
interested to go deep
and have specialized
knowledge, to kind of go
in an academic way, or
those who really needed
general background, and how to
try to design a curriculum that
met both of those needs.
They recommended some changes.
And they urged that
instructors should
read the comments of the
students in their own courses
and that the chairs
of departments
should read the comments
of all of the students
in the faculty
within a department.
And as far as I can tell--
and I would love to
know differently--
all of the efforts
that came after that,
no one knew that
there was a precursor
to course evaluations in 1902.
We just keep reinventing things.
All right.
Just to give a sense of
how this keeps coming up.
There was a report
of the Committee
on Instruction in 1927.
A report in 1945.
A series of essays in 1969.
Through the '70s and the '80s,
there were a bunch of efforts
that, as far as I can tell, were
led by President Bok and Dean
Rosovsky at the time.
And that really
was around trying
to formalize course evaluations.
A report of the task force on
pedagogical improvement in 1977
takes multiple
pages to lay out how
to evaluate teaching, guidelines
for how to evaluate teaching.
You could have written it today.
It's a great summary of all
the things that you could do.
It's multi-method, it's there.
I'm not going to keep listing
these throughout time.
I want to read one
note from a letter,
from a professor of English
and comparative literature.
It was written in
1975 to his dean.
And I just thought it helped
to underscore another way
in which these issues are hard.
The only thing that
can conceivably
be said in favor of the
course evaluation project
is that its finished product
is virtually unreadable.
But I would sooner resign
my professorship at Harvard
than collaborate in any way
with such a hateful undertaking
which demeans those
who participate in it.
It goes against everything
Harvard ought to stand for
and is postulated on an
almost total misunderstanding
of what education is about.
It seems to me,
a graphic example
of the perversion of
values that characterizes
the entire undertaking that the
Dean of Undergraduate Affairs
should ask me to forego 15
minutes of educational time
to enable students to fill out
a meaningless questionnaire.
It is also, I might add,
practically impossible.
My lectures are not
haphazard musings.
They are each carefully
contrived to present
a specific body of material
to precisely 53 minutes.
So it's hard to make
change at this institution.
So to the last point,
requires collaboration,
I think it's precisely
because it's so hard.
Meaningful evaluation
of teaching,
it requires
collaboration and trust.
And collaboration and trust
across different roles.
And again, I want to pause for
a moment and come back to today.
We've designed this
conference with people
with lots of different
roles on purpose.
Partnerships between
academic professional staff
who support teaching
and learning,
and instructors, and faculty,
and deans, are so important.
And building up
those lines of trust,
if we want to make a
difference, is so important.
So when I think about really
trying to make progress
on evaluating teaching,
I think there's
no way it doesn't involve
chairs of departments, faculty
and instructors talking
with one another,
really listening to students.
What the students need,
what do they care about?
Where do they come in
understanding or not
understanding?
How did they think
about teaching?
about their instructors?
And this is something
that we, in hilt,
have not been able to do
as well as I would like to.
An initiative around
learning and teaching,
how do we involve
students, I think
it's critically important
that we all do better
at listening to our students.
I would like to invite president
Faust and our distinguished
university professors
to come up and we'll
start this conversation.
Thank you, Erin.
I love listening to those
historical tidbits, obviously.
But Erin shared a substantial
amount of material
with us about the past as
preparation for this panel,
so I thought it might be
good to begin with that.
By the way, does everyone
know who's up here?
You have bios, and I don't
have to introduce anybody?
Should I introduce people?
No.
OK.
So I thought I'd just begin
by asking your reflections
on the opportunity that Erin
gave us to dive into some
of the elements of the
past and I'll go historian
to historian here to start.
And again, if you would.
Well, I thought the
research was terrific.
And obviously, her point
that these issues have long
been with us is amazing.
The students seem to
have gotten to it first.
So in 1925, they set
up the Confi Guide,
which was still going
in the '80s when
I was an undergraduate.
But then it sort of faded
at some point between then
and now as Hugh really
stepped up its work.
What really struck me was a
comment from a student in I
think it was the 1902
survey that she described
saying that he had taken
a particular course
with a particular
goal, and he'd gotten
what he wanted out of
it, the literary work,
the grade he'd hoped for, but
he hadn't felt it as satisfying.
And he says, as is usual
when one engages in things
for mercenary purposes.
That was a fascinating entry
into how students, even then,
were conscious of
their different motives
for taking courses.
And when always hopes that
takes courses out of interest.
Other reflections, Gary?
Or Doug?
First of all, congratulations
on your promotion
back to the faculty.
So I think that the
history was great because,
in the social and
behavioral sciences--
Drew is going from
division to the division--
we actually know a lot
more about evaluation
and about how to elicit
information from people
than they did in 1875.
So right now, we're
evaluating at the wrong time,
we're asking the
wrong questions,
and we have the wrong
outcome variable.
So it's the wrong time because--
imagine the Olympic
diving practice
where someone
dives and the coach
says, no, your toe was
wrong, get up, do it again.
Then they do it again.
And they say, no,
your leg went off.
Suppose instead, the coach just
watched for the whole weekend.
And then, at the
end of the weekend,
they patted somebody on the
back, and said, good job.
How much would they learn?
Not very much.
So if you're one us
as teachers to learn,
you don't evaluate once
at the end of the year,
you do it in continuous time.
That doesn't mean you
ask students questions
in continuous time.
You find ways of doing it
in unobtrusive ways that
doesn't get in the
way of teaching,
but it needs to be frequent.
Instant feedback helps learning
of students and of faculty
as well.
Second, it's we have the wrong
questions a lot of times.
If you go have an
operation at the hospital,
suppose they ask you a survey,
how was the doctor's technique?
That's not information
you actually have.
If we want to know
who's going to win
the presidential election,
we don't ask a random sample
of people who you
think is going to win
the presidential election
for each and every person,
because you don't have access
to information unless you happen
to be a researcher.
Right?
We asked you what
you know, which is,
who are going to vote for?
So we need to ask the
questions the right way.
And finally, the
outcome is not what
the students say they learned.
It's whether they
actually learned
and whether they remember
it a long time from now.
Right?
And so we should
measure the things
that we actually care about.
We actually know about
these things now.
We should bring
some social science
into what we're studying.
Doug, any thoughts?
I agree with what Gary said.
What struck me in reading it was
maybe dispiriting in the sense
that things haven't
really changed,
that the challenge between
the teacher and the student
remains the same.
Students who want to
be entertained or have
some other reason
for taking the class.
And the teachers are trying
to convey information.
And that-- I don't know what
that's called-- that contract,
or that interaction
remains a challenge.
But what struck me
more than anything
was that Harvard
professors gave low grades.
There were many comments
about A's, B's, C's and D's.
And I mean, if I were
to ask in this room
to raise your hand
if you've given a D,
let's see how many people
have given a D. Yeah, right.
It's a very small number.
And so grade inflation has
been the biggest change
I would say comparing to what
they were concerned about
and how we evaluate
students now.
But Gary brought up another
point that also struck me that
made me think about
evaluations in the longer term,
and if I had any idea about
how to change evaluation--
and I don't have many ideas--
one would be, to Erin's
point of cooperation,
to engage with the--
I forgot what HAA stands for,
Harvard Alumni Association--
and to give tests or evaluations
five years after students
have graduated.
They ask them, what
do you remember?
What's been useful?
And they were to challenge
departments and the faculty.
Like, what kinds of questions
would you want to ask?
Which would clearly
be different from what
you would ask, as Gary said,
during the rush of learning,
the discipline at the time.
You know, I get a kind
of anecdotal window
into that often when
I'm meeting with alums.
One of my favorite aspects of
that is when one will tell me,
I will never forget this course
that I took 25 years ago.
And I've thought
about it every day.
And maybe I should be more
systematic and make a list
and at least tell the people,
if they're still alive,
what the course was.
If I can say
something about what
Erin said that makes
me a little more
optimistic than the assertion
that nothing's changed,
it just seems to be the way
everyone laughed at the comment
from the comparative
lit professor in 1975--
is that right?
That's the year I got my PhD.
So it doesn't seem all
that distant in time to me.
But no one would dare
say that now, right?
It's more embedded in our
expectations of ourselves
and our students'
expectations of us
that there will be evaluations.
And it was while
I was at Harvard,
I can't remember
if I was at grad
or was yet president that the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences
voted that there
should be course
evaluations in every course.
Up until then, it was voluntary.
So I think it's become
more a part of the culture,
that there should be
evaluation of teaching.
One thing, Gary, that your
comments raised in my mind
and that I've been
thinking about
since we began
having conversations
about this session
is, if we're thinking
about what successful teaching
is, that's so hard to define.
Is it helpful to think about
what is unsuccessful teaching?
And what would be
information about teaching
that you would think, this
is a science, not working.
So I'm going to connect
to your last two points.
So I actually did collect some
of the information you thought
of collecting
systematically, only I
have a much narrower sample.
So my sample is I go--
like everyone else
here-- go to give talks
at other universities.
And I'll see a student that
took my course 20 years ago.
So what I started
doing a few years ago
is asking them about it.
And what they say
is, you know, I
remember when you
did that thing.
Are you still doing that thing?
And most of the time,
the answer is yes.
But I actually want to know
whether I'm doing that thing,
right?
And so I actually have a
systematic collection--
What is that thing?
Is it something--
That's right.
So that thing is different
for different people.
Oh, OK.
And that's the way
that they describe it.
I mean, I could describe it
now, but probably shouldn't.
But so I collected those things.
And then I went to psychology
and asked them, well,
what things do we remember
20 years from now?
And so there's actually
an answer which
helps me design new classes.
So the answer is
that there are things
that are surprising, unusual,
and have emotional content.
So if you can't make
your students cry,
then you can make
them laugh, you
can make them surprised
and interested.
But doing something doing
something different.
You know, I do this
thing where I climb up
on chairs for a particular
substantive purpose.
Like, you don't want them to
remember that you did something
dumb, you want them to
remember that it connects
to some intellectual point.
So there's research
on this, too.
Any thoughts about
unsuccessful teaching?
Gary, you had talked about that.
Sorry, just to connect
it, the unsuccessful part
was all the parts
they didn't remember.
And sometimes, that's
why we teach, right?
If they don't take it with
them, what's the point?
Well, on the notion of
asking alums, first of all,
it's going to be hard.
It's hard enough to get
undergraduates to fill out
these questionnaires, and now
we've made them conditional,
they can get their grades
early if they fill them out.
So that got our
percentage of completion
much high up into the
'90s of percentages.
And it's still not 100% now.
So I worry about asking
alums to do tests,
it's not going to
necessarily work.
You know, I was just thinking,
there are all these surveys
that the HAA takes of alums.
Like, did you ever hear
about the sex survey
that one class took?
Every single alum showed up for
the session on that reunion.
But I wonder if they do put
questions about teaching
into HAA surveys?
We should think about that.
I think that would
be fascinating.
Anyway, excuse me
for interrupting.
I think the next question to ask
is, what kind of course, also,
do they remember?
Was it the elective or
thing they took sort of
at the last minute or on a whim?
Or was it a required course?
Or especially, a vivid one?
I think, clearly, just
remembering which courses
you took is the first rule.
And if you can get
remembered for something
you didn't class as
a tremendous success.
Have you ever had an
experience where you thought,
this was an unsuccessful
teaching experience?
And you thought again about how
you were approaching something?
Yeah, I mean, revamping a
course and restructuring it,
deciding that--
and I think I'm still
wanting to restructure
the course I'm
currently teaching
on the history of the book.
So I've never felt like a
complete disaster, usually.
But of course, immediately
after lecturing,
I always have a list of
things I wish I'd said.
And of course, now
I've learned to thing
to do is to write those
down and to put them
at the top of the
lecture for next time
so that they can get
factored in earlier.
And restructuring, I
suppose, that's the challenge
that it might be good
to share with students,
is how teaching
is a constant set
of decisions about tradeoff.
And there isn't a perfect
solution, frankly.
And so sometimes--
I remember one
of the questions we
got in the head was,
what's the most powerful
question you'd ask a student?
And I was thinking
I might ask them,
what would you do differently?
You know, ask them
to put themselves
in my position of having
to structure a course
and make decisions
that work more or less
well for different people, too.
We're talking to so
many different audiences
in the same classroom.
So all three of you are
university professors,
highly honored scholars,
and teachers and members
of the community.
And that both
reflects your impact
on the university
as a whole, but also
encourages you to reach
beyond your own fields
and your own
particular disciplines.
How is teaching different?
What have your experience
has been teaching
outside the particular
field or area in which you
got your graduate
degree or in which
you were originally identified?
What's that been like?
And what have you
learned from that?
Maybe I'll take a stab at it.
If I think of what's
been the best learning
experience for me,
it's teaching a course
with a person many of you
know, Michael Sandel, called
Biotechnology and The
Future of Human Nature.
And I've learned a
lot about teaching
from teaching with
Michael, who is really
an excellent professor.
The broader question
to ask is, what's it
like to, say, teach
in the medical school
versus the college, or teach
different kinds of courses?
I find each experience
quite different.
Frankly, I don't
enjoy much, and I
do rather a little teaching
of medical students,
because they're, on
the whole, trying
to learn discipline
and learn facts.
The graduate students
are different.
Maybe one of the
most enjoyable things
I do, but I don't do it
very often, every few years,
is teach a freshman seminar.
That's so fun because they
don't know what to expect.
And it's really nice to
just have people completely
come unbiased to say what
college is going to be like.
I guess the other
thing I've learned
is, unfortunately, impractical.
If you ask me, how would
I-- to Gary's point--
best evaluate teaching?
It's by oral exams.
And I only give those
as makeup exams.
Because, I mean, even for
a class of 20 students,
you can't give 20,
three hour oral exams.
It's just not possible.
If someone could
solve that problem,
I think an oral exam
is probably the best
way to evaluate teaching.
But I think we can't do it.
So it's not a very good answer.
Not great.
Well, this semester, I
am, for the first time,
teaching an extension
in addition to
teaching in a college.
And I'm very grateful for the
way the Extension School has
worked out lots of pieces
of technology and ways
of using technology as part
of your teaching, which
I'm trying to take onboard
even in the classroom, too.
And it makes one
aware, obviously,
the extension school
is very different.
Being a bit older--
not necessarily, though, I have
a high school student in there.
And yeah, it's a
feeling of reaching out
beyond just our little world,
is a good one, I think.
Although, I see there are
limits to how that can be done.
But I'm very pleased.
Do you find that these students
bring different questions
to the material?
Absolutely.
And they also are each
very passionate about it.
They're putting more on the
line as it were, taking time out
of working lives, and expenses
for that course, which
is a very unusual interaction.
Is this course worth what
you're spending on it?
Which is, thankfully,
not a a question
I have to ask the undergrads
in quite that direct a way,
but it does mean they're
also very invested.
And they do bring
different questions.
Sometimes it hasn't
been a long time
since they've taken a
course or had a grand scheme
of historical periodization.
But it's really helpful.
I mean, I learn a tremendous
amount from my students.
You know?
Also, the undergraduates,
of course.
And that's what's so
great about teaching
is that it's
constantly a learning
experience for oneself.
So I teach this
course where I have
students from lots
of different schools,
and the undergraduates as
well, and graduate students.
And I've actually had
students from every school,
but unfortunately, not
in the same semester.
But there are lots.
There are lots.
And what you said, actually,
is exactly my experience,
it's the questions they ask.
That's really the only thing
that differs across the areas,
because they're united by
their interest in research
in some way, or the products
of research, or maybe doing it.
I teach methods, so it's
sort of how to do it.
Myself, actually, I've been
trying to write something
on exactly this question.
And I'm designing a component
of my class for the spring
that's--
the issue is that
from kindergarten
up through graduate school,
people are given a question
and then good students
do their absolute
best to answer that immutable,
unchangeable, fixed question.
But the moment we graduate,
we're given any question we
want.
We can change the
question along the way.
If we're researchers,
and we've decided
to go interview
Indian legislators,
but we trip over an archive
of interesting information
in New Jersey, like,
a great thing to do
is to switch topics.
Students are never
given that task.
And so I've often tried to get
them to change the question.
But it's much easier
in the context
of people whose
discipline defines
questions in different ways.
So when the
undergraduates see people
from the School of Public
Health and they realize
that could be an interesting
question, or across
all the schools.
And so I'm trying to figure
out how to bottle that.
Because that's an important
part of the learning process.
They're learning from
the different culture
of public health, or the
different culture of whatever.
That's great.
In their silo,
they learn what is
culturally important in
that group of people.
And they're very
different groups.
Like, in economics, you
take two graduate students,
send them to different
graduate schools
on different parts
of the planet,
they take the same courses.
You take to
political scientists,
send them to the same program,
they take different courses.
In public health or in
medicine or whatever
it is, they analyze
questions very deeply
that, in many areas,
you would never
think in the sciences would be
acceptable as a broad enough
area.
But we need people doing that.
And so giving people
the understanding that,
you know what, there
could be an audience
for your interesting
question in a different area.
And what is an
interesting question
is just-- it's
culturally defined.
You can find an important
question in lots
of different areas,
can be important.
Listening to Gary
reminds me that one thing
I think the university's
done extremely well,
and you've supported, Drew,
is to bring to us a much more
diverse student body.
And that's definitely
changed in my time here.
And I think, for me, one
of our next challenges
now is to change this
national discussion about,
what do I get out of college
in terms of how much money I'll
make or what job I'll get,
and recenter the discussion
on changing who you are as a
person, you know, how to think,
what a liberal arts
education means.
And I think our nation
is losing that aspect
of advanced education.
I don't have any idea
what to do about it.
I mean--
I think you raised a really
important point, which
is the external pressures
that would have us evaluate
our teaching and our
effectiveness based
on salary at first job.
That was one right
one suggestion
that is so reductionist.
And I'm often asked, well,
what would you use instead?
So that really puts
the question of,
how do we evaluate,
front and center,
in defining what our mission is?
Because essentially, this
question of evaluation is what
makes this a successful
institution and what doesn't?
So it really has enormous
implications as you point out,
Doug.
It's true.
Well, Gary, you kind
of started this off
with a pretty searing
critique of the current way
of evaluating, or at least
with student evaluations.
Do you think they have any use?
Should they be supplemented?
Should they be abandoned?
And how would you move us to
the suggestions that you --?
So during the era of
big data, of the ability
to collect and analyze many
more forms of information
than we ever had
before, the books
that Erin found by sleuthing
through the library
have unstructured text.
Which, for a century, we
didn't know how to analyze.
And there were too
many of them to read
and really comprehend
all at once because
of so many different classes.
Actually, we know how
to analyze them now.
What a great project
for someone Somebody
should go back and do that.
But I think we should go collect
a lot of forms of information.
I don't want my teaching
evaluated based only
on whether students get a
job that make a lot of money,
at a famous place,
or whatever it is.
But I would like to
know that information.
Moreover, I think
my students might
like to know that information
as one of many components.
And actually,
there's a lot more.
So I think with digital
technology in particular,
we can give faculty
continuous time
feedback on certain
aspects of what they do,
and exactly how students read.
Eric Mazur and I have a project
called Perusall where students
read, and they annotate a
reading, and collaboratively,
answer each other's questions.
We then know every movement
they make, everything they're
reading, everything about it.
We use that for them.
So it feeds back
information to them.
And we can say, you
know, you are reading
in a particular way, that
in previous semesters,
hasn't really worked.
Here's a suggestion,
in an automated
or non-humiliating private way.
Similarly, if the
instructor is assigning
something that is not working,
the instructor gets to know.
If there is material
that, on particular pages,
that students don't understand
or engaging with because
they're making comments so
they're going back to it
and they're reading it
again, we can print off--
and we do-- a one page
student confusion report,
that the instructor can walk
into the class the next time,
and just say, you know,
there's three things
that you're confused about.
Which is so much
better than what
I used to do, which is I would
walk into a class and say,
any questions?
They all have questions.
They never know them
when you ask them.
Right?
Because they just
trumped across campus,
they dropped their book
bag, and their coat,
and they're preparing to
be entertained, right?
But if we actually
know what's going
to generate the questions-- so
there's three things that you
don't understand,
here's the first one,
and then they ask
questions because they
remember what it is.
I love the idea of
a confusion report.
I'm thinking of
all kinds of ways
we can benefit from
confusion reports.
Anne, are there
things you'd like
to know that your teaching?
I mean, you said you'd
like to know what someone
thinks 10 years later, but
other than that or in addition
to that?
I think one thing I
learned from the Bok center
actually is this
quick response survey
at the end of class,
one thing you learned,
one question you have.
And to start sending
out an index card
is the efficient way of doing
that, and collecting them,
which, actually, then gives you
fodder to start up next time.
But I have also used
clickers to ask questions
that I wouldn't want
even a show of hands for,
but that people can answer.
So yes, I think some kind
of continuous feedback
would be fantastic at the level
of the lecturer or the class
meeting.
And then also, I think a
mid-semester questionnaire
is key in any case.
And there, a quick form
that people check boxes off
so there's no
handwriting and so on.
But even a kind of a journal,
I think, would be good.
If we could ask students to
think about what's going on,
I don't know, every two
weeks or something like that.
And actually, I
think, for me, to keep
a journal would also be good
and trying to do more of that.
So annotate my syllabus
for my own use next time.
You know, what worked, what
didn't work, and so on.
So that we could have-- and
then how that might be shared?
I don't know.
If the continuous thoughtfulness
of thinking about the process,
of teaching and of learning.
Actually, one thing I find
really helpful in a freshmen
discussion group, in
those opening days,
was to ask what their
vision of teaching is.
I suppose one of
the classic models
if you have a pitcher
of stuff that you're
pouring into someone's brain.
And you know,
obviously, no one can--
that is actually an underlying
metaphor that a lot of people
have.
And yet when you think
about it, it's ridiculous.
You know, you're asking someone
to form, in their own brain,
on their own, by interaction
with their peers, us,
and just to get them thinking
about what learning means
and what might be involved
on their part versus my part
I think is great.
So more metacognition
all along the way, maybe.
Obviously, you don't
want to over analyze.
That's another risk, you know.
Right.
Doug, any thoughts on this?
Well, I agree with
what's been said.
And another aspect I
think we might consider
is something I know I've
discussed with Rob Liu,
and Bill Anderson, and others,
is it's more difficult to do,
but it's using the faculty
to evaluate the teaching.
That's really very
touchy business, right?
To have your colleagues come
into class and say, you know--
It's retainment in law school
in the business school.
It is, right.
But I can tell you it's a
touchy business in the FAS.
OK.
And I think that
that's something
that we should somehow
encourage more.
We had an unfortunately
bad experience
in my department, where I
think we try to pride ourselves
on good teaching, is a
new course was offered
and it was, by any
measure, a failure.
The faculty didn't think it went
well and the students didn't.
And so we had a faculty
meeting with the two faculty
members who taught it and
a lot of student feedback.
And that turned out to be a
very good event, is to say,
this is our responsibility
as a department
to make this course better.
How do we help you
teach it better?
How do we listen to
student complaints?
Really, there were complaints.
But I don't have a good idea.
I know more about how the
business school does it,
where they have people
sit-in on classes.
That takes faculty time.
I don't know how to solve it.
But I think in
terms of evaluation,
evaluating teachers
as well as students.
I guess part of this is--
I don't know about others, but
I find the cue guide very hard
to read for my own assessments.
I tend to focus--
because of my ego, I guess--
on all of these bad comments.
You know?
Those are the ones I remember,
that he was a terrible teacher,
he didn't care about
students, he was unavailable,
he was intimidating.
And even if that's a
small number of them,
those are the ones
that I remember.
So I started to not
read them so often.
I'd wait till the summer
and read them when
I'm on vacation or something.
We've been focused on
teaching as classroom,
I think, mostly here.
And one of the things
that I'm struck
by when I see ad
hoc files and we're
trying to evaluate teaching by
people who are being suggested
for promotion or appointment.
Is there are many
kinds of teaching?
And not everybody is a performer
in a large lecture course,
or the kind of charismatic
actor that is so valued
in the student evaluation.
So how do we think about the
other dimensions of teaching?
One's being a thesis advisor,
being in a small group.
And Doug, I was
thinking that you also
are involved in a
form of teaching that
goes beyond the
academic program itself
in your role as a faculty
dean at Elliott House.
You were teaching day and night.
And that is the Harvard
model for the college,
that teaching takes
place everywhere.
So how do we think
about evaluating?
What should I do when
I get a ad hoc file
and I'm thinking about
teaching and wondering
is someone a good
graduate teacher,
or a good mentor,
or a good colleague,
and teaching junior faculty.
All those things.
I wouldn't pay
too much attention
to the Q Guide scores.
I'm not convinced that
that's the best measure.
I think it's helpful
to some, but I don't
think that's the best measure.
But you're right,
the one house I know,
Elliot House, when I asked the
students, the most interesting
conversations about
how they weave together
the things they've learned
in Anne or Gary's course,
and try to make
those connections.
And so how we do that as a
faculty is a real challenge.
The other thing I'm
sorry to tell you all
is when I usually ask them
who's teaching that course,
they can't remember the
name of the professor.
They have no idea.
They can sometimes describe
what he or she looks like,
but they seldom know
the professor's name.
That I find surprising.
But it is a universal
effect among the students.
Particularly, if the course
was taught last year,
they have no idea.
They have to look it
up on their iPhone
to remember who taught them.
I find that when
I ask students--
you know, making
conversation, when
I interact with
them-- say, you're
taking x, who's teaching it?
That's about teaching outside.
To answer your question about in
your position and the ad hocs,
how to evaluate teaching,
that's an important issue.
I don't know.
What do you two think?
Well, one on one teaching
is a crucial part
of what goes on
in the humanities.
And those people
don't remember who
they are thesis advisor was.
That's right.
That's one way the teacher,
actually, I think, sticks.
And one thing I have seen
done at other institutions
is to have students write
for their teachers, actually.
But it is difficult to get
insight into that very direct--
obviously, though, you can
judge by how many, perhaps.
In some cases, someone who--
because there's a
lot of word of mouth,
I think, which
sort of translates
into student behavior.
I would say the cue guide
is doing a real service
to the students in
terms of advising them,
what the science
courses will say,
well, I have this
background, and I thought
this course was hard or easy.
And you know, those
kinds of things
are valuable students advice.
I agree about when to
read one's cue scores.
Well, after the
fact, when relaxed,
and when having a chance to
sort of decompress afterwards.
Because there are always
inevitable disappointments.
One thought that
someone suggested is you
could throw out the
lowest eval and highest
eval, sort of way of detracting
from the overall score being
brought down by a fluke.
And the other phenomenon
to be aware of,
too, is that the bigger the
course, the lower the score,
then the course shrinks, then
the course gets higher cue
scores, then of course grows,
then it gets lower cue scores.
And on we go.
I mean, that's
sort of the cycle.
So I suppose the course
reaches equilibrium somewhere
in between these gyrations.
But it's hard.
For you to get a
view is difficult.
So Gary, is there a way to
use big data to evaluate?
Well, the answer's
always yes, but I'm going
to give a different question.
That's comforting.
So I think even the amazing
people that you consider,
these ad hocs have a finite
amount of time in their lives.
And so one of the additional
questions that I would hope
you would ask is,
is there teaching
and research life incentive
compatible with each other?
Because if it's
not, then they need
to be devoting as much time
as they can to research
and as much time
they can to teaching.
But if they're
teaching something
unrelated to the
research, you know,
they're just not
going to be doing
as well as the sum of the two.
So this is actually
important for another reason.
I think that we want all of the
people that through ad hoc--
and you're shaking
your head yes--
they all are going to be
above some level of teaching.
But 100% of them,
without any question,
are going to be
great researchers.
And we have to spend most
of the time in the ad hoc
on the research.
So the thing that gets them up
in the morning, the thing that
got most people here, the
thing that is of most interest
and most exciting to people,
actually is research.
But if you want to be a great
teacher, what do you teach?
What gets you excited?
That's the thing
that's going to be
most interesting to the
students, it's your research.
So I think-- and
then let's look at it
from the student perspective.
I think it is almost a
travesty for a student
to go four years through
an institution like this
and not at least once have
an experience where they're
sitting at the table, making
some contribution that they're
capable of making, when they
see a discovery being made.
I'm not talking about
them doing research.
They should do that,
but that's separate.
I mean, when Doug
or Ann says, ah-hah,
that is a life
changing experience
akin to the kind of
stories that we tell
about when a student
goes to a foreign country
and spends a year.
But this is an experience
that Harvard can give them.
So that's the
question I would ask.
So that raises the
question of how
is teaching different
and special in a research
university?
And I think you framed an
important aspect of that
in what you've just said.
Any other thoughts about the
research, teaching connection,
Anne or Doug?
It's a very tight one,
for me, absolutely.
And I suppose that speaks to how
many different kinds of courses
one teaches.
I always feel that you should
stretch yourself and teach
in different-- but then, you're
actually actively researching
one of those different areas
you might be teaching in.
And that's a delicate
balance, as you say.
Because on the one hand, if
I keep teaching things that
are sort of adjacent to
your current research,
you're bringing in new
insights into that research.
And yet, if you spread
yourself too thin, then
maybe you don't have the same
level of enthusiasm or ability
to translate research
into teaching.
So it is a delicate balance.
But think that the two are--
that is the excitement, really.
And of course, there's
graduate teaching
that's happening in here, too.
And that the undergraduate
teaching is also
mentoring graduate
students, teachers
of those undergraduates,
and when all three levels
sync nicely, it's really great.
Now that I think
of it, it relates
to your question about
how you evaluate teaching.
And maybe I'll
exaggerate a bit, but I
don't think in the natural
sciences in undergraduate
would ever say the thing
that changed their life was
of course they took.
It was instead the lab
in which they worked.
It was, to Anne's point, about
establishing a relationship
with a mentor and a teacher
that they saw out of class.
And I don't actually know how
much that counts in the ad hoc.
I can't remember.
I mean, same in my
lab, which I know best,
there's about seven to 10
undergraduates every term
working in the lab.
I don't even think I get
credit for that-- maybe I do.
I can't remember
how that counts.
But I mean, that's sort of
the most intense teaching
that you do, in a laboratory.
And again, I know
Rob Liu's been very
keen on making
laboratory experiences
available for undergraduates.
And the way we count that
both as course credit
and in terms of
your evaluation, it
might be something
worth revisiting.
Well, we get lists
often of, these students
worked in the lab, or I
have this many PhD students.
But we don't get much evaluation
of the quality of that.
We have to assume that
the quantity of them
is a reflection of the
quality of the instruction.
And it strikes me
also that we're
learning a lot from each other
about how to teach better based
on the evaluative mechanisms.
We talk a lot about what
makes a good classroom,
but I don't think we
thought very much about what
makes a good lab instructor, or
what makes a good dissertation
director.
How do you work most
effectively in those realms?
And that would be something
that I would think
would be really interesting.
Big data has the answer to that.
So you're asking a deep
research question, not one
that we can answer by
just sort of writing up
a couple of questions
and asking somebody.
You're asking the causal effect
of a researcher, of a professor
or a mentor on the student.
So let's first define
the quantity of interest,
what we actually care about.
And then let's figure out
how we can estimate it.
Right?
So let's just separate the two.
So the thing that we
actually want to know
is you have two students that
are identical, let's imagine,
coming through the program.
And one is mentored
by me and one
is mentored by someone else.
And we want to know
what the effect is
of their whole career,
and how much they
liked it, and all
of the outcomes
that you could
possibly think of.
That's a very difficult
thing to estimate.
In the last 20 or 30
years, actually, we've
learned a lot about
causal inference.
This is a very
difficult subject.
We could design studies
to answer this question.
You match students that
are not exactly the same.
Then you correct for
the fact that they
differ in certain ways.
You can't randomly
assign them to faculty.
They get to choose,
but those are
threats to inference
that we can deal with.
It's a big research
project, but I
think we should engage in that.
And I'm thinking just about
a very utilitarian dimension
of knowing that.
Let's say you're a
scientist in a lab
and you have nine
students working with you.
And there's another
scientist who has two.
And that scientist is aware
she or he is struggling
to figure out why don't
students want to work with me,
it's not my field.
What is it that you
say to that person
or that somebody could
say that person about what
your magic fairy dust is that
the other person doesn't have?
Do we know that?
I don't think we do, because
if we observe differences
between the two, there's an
entirely different question.
So we observe these differences.
I do this thing,
they do that thing.
I have two students,
they have 10 students.
And so if I start-- then there's
an entirely different question,
which is, suppose I start to
do what that person is doing,
would I get 10 students or
would I lose my two students?
We know democracies do better
than the non-democracies.
But we know also that when
you take a non-democracy
and you try to make
it a democracy,
that doesn't actually work.
That's great.
Doug, you said
something a minute ago
that raises a
question in my mind
about the moment in
which we find ourselves.
And it was your comment that
most meaningful experience
for a science student
is almost inevitably
a laboratory experience rather
than a classroom experience.
And as you said that, I was
thinking about the implications
of that for digital learning
and how we now are in a moment
where we need to say, we have
residential education which is
incredibly complicated,
incredibly expensive,
because we believe it cannot be
replaced entirely by learning
online.
So what are the aspects of
the residential, face to face
in Cambridge or in
Boston experience that we
need to foreground and nurture?
And what have the digital
tools added to your quiver
in terms of teaching options?
And how do you see
the relationship
between what you do
face to face and what
you can't do face to face?
There's a lot in there.
I would say digital tools
have been extremely valuable
and sort of data transfer.
So that you could say gets
around just a lot of data
dumping to students for facts
they can learn on their own.
They're very good at that.
But your point about
hands on experience,
which is almost
a hackneyed term,
is extremely important in my
area of the life sciences.
So you can watch a video
of a mouse being dissected,
but it's nothing like picking
that mouse up, killing it,
slicing it open, and looking
inside its body parts.
Thank God!
That's something--
that's something
you don't ever forget the first
time you looked inside a mouse.
And that's true for
all aspects of sort
of experimental science.
And again, in my field,
in biomedicine, we are,
I think, unquestionably
in the richest community
of that in the world.
There's opportunities
for the students
to work in the biotech
industry at the hospitals.
That is nothing
you can even come
close to experiencing online.
And to your point, I
think that is something
we should emphasize for
the residential learning,
is that hands on experience
of dealing with nature.
That's something
you just can't do.
Even though I do like those
Attenborough nature programs,
whatever they're
called, Planet Earth.
I've learned a lot from them.
It's just different
doing it yourself.
And evaluate how we're
getting the proper balance
or not is evolving.
Well, of course,
hands on experiences
are much more expensive.
But I wouldn't be opposed to
reducing the number of classes
students took and increasing
their laboratory experiences.
There's hands on in the
humanities, absolutely.
For me, what comes to mind is,
in Houghton Library, you know,
you get to handle books that
are hundreds of years old.
It's the oldest thing
most students will ever
touch barring some European
building in the Middle Ages,
maybe.
But it's very powerful for them.
And it is something
that, obviously, can only
be done in small numbers.
And yet, it's well worth
the considerable expense.
That's one of the great
privileges of being here.
And that goes back
in some ways, I
think, to what Gary said early
on about what people remember,
something that they're
emotionally linked to.
A live experience has, I
think, more emotional resonance
than a digital medium.
Absolutely.
Books are now digitized.
And they're great tools for
accessing the text at any hour,
and looking at it
closely, and zooming in,
and all that good stuff.
But I really hope that digital
engagement is married to one
a physical one, where you
still see the book itself,
and you can ask different
kinds of questions
from looking at
the object itself.
Should we be taking this
into account in some way
and should we be concerned about
colleagues or should students
be concerned about
colleagues who aren't taking
advantage of these
opportunities?
Is that an important
dimension of how
we think about our teaching?
If we actually do the
research and we demonstrate
that it has an
effect then there has
to be a reason to not use it.
But I don't think
we know the answers
to all the questions
yet or to many of them.
Well, obviously, a colleague--
I mean, designing your
own form of experience
is the key element.
And for some people, it may be
a really engaging discussion
on a difficult topic, could
have a similarly powerful
experiential component
to working in a lab,
going to see a real book.
So I wouldn't want to
put any constraints
on what constitutes
active learning
that way, hands on learning.
One of the elements
that we often
use as a justification purpose
for a liberal arts education
is to talk about critical
thinking and ways of thinking.
Do we understand
that and how we're
doing in meeting that goal?
Is there a way to
see an evolution?
I know there was a
critical thinking
exam that was given in a
number of institutions.
And I think it was
difficult for our students--
it was so easy for our
students, actually,
that we didn't get
much variation.
They all turned out to be
fabulous critical thinkers
on this scale.
So the scale was wrong, I guess.
But are there ways
that you evaluate that?
You evaluate whether
you're succeeding
at that in your students,
with your students?
Can I go tell
everybody in Congress
that we're building
critical thinkers
and I have the
evidence to prove it?
I don't know.
I'm not sure I know what
critical thinking means.
But in the sciences,
one thing we try to do
is to force students
to design experiments
that answer your questions
about the unknown.
So if that's critical
thinking, then I
think that is an important
thing about what we do.
Rather than telling
them what is known,
saying these are
interesting problems,
how would you solve it?
And I'd hope that we
teach them the kind
of disciplinary knowledge
they need to know what
techniques and approaches
they could take to a problem.
But that's when they
get most excited,
is something where they can
make, as Ann said, a discovery.
And in another way, you make
me think about how do we
encourage curiosity
rather than simply what
I call data transfer?
That's really what's so
exciting in the freshmen,
is they're just curious
about everything.
I'd say, in history,
we've built ourself
a tutorial around
writing and rewriting,
and critically engaging
with secondary sources
and primary sources.
And I really do think we see a
progression in the way students
write at the beginning of
the term and at the end.
In particular, the
big hurdle, usually,
is the concept of
historiography,
in other words, what
other historians have
said about the past,
and how you can
engage with the
past in conversation
with those historians.
And it's not what
people expect when
they walk into history course.
And it takes a certain
amount of going over it
in from multiple
angles, but I hope
that by the end of the
semester, most people
have gotten that key
move, sort of, meta move.
And they may or may
not deploy it later.
But the whole point is to
create that possibility,
for example, a senior thesis.
Anything thoughts on
critical thinking?
Big data on critical thinking?
Well, I mean, like
Doug, I also don't
know exactly what that means.
And that's definitely
not the right thing
to say to members of Congress.
I would say that it
basically involves
some kind of deep thinking
about a subject, which
involves a real motivation.
It sort of connects
all the things
that we've been talking about.
And so what I was thinking
about when you were talking
is sometimes I get
to talk to a student
and they explain their paper to
me-- this is back to my theme
about getting them
involved in research,
and either they're
involved in my research,
or I'm helping them
with their research--
and there's a moment, in
addition to the one I described
earlier, where I point out
something in their research,
and I say, I didn't know this.
And they look at
me and they said,
what do you mean you
didn't know that?
You're the professor.
And I get to say, no,
you don't understand.
Not only did I not know this,
but no one in the history
the world has ever known this.
And you know this.
Right?
I remember when
I was a sophomore
and I had that experience.
And I thought, like, I
don't know what cocaine is,
but I'm glad I got this first.
Because I have to do
it again and again.
And that's the kind
of thing that it's not
critical thinking,
it's motivation.
But once you have
that motivation,
you devote all of
your efforts to it.
You think critically, you think
obsessively, you work on it.
I love the cocaine.
In the course of the discussion
so far, a couple of you
have raised the issue
of vulnerability.
And when Doug said he finds
it hard to read his teaching
evaluations, and I have
to say, if he finds
it hard to read his
teaching evaluations,
I can imagine they're
only wonderful, Doug, so--
No.
They're not.
But what about that element?
Erin was talking about it.
To be open to evaluation, to
really make evaluations work,
we have to have a willingness
for faculty to be vulnerable.
And Erin talked about
building communities of trust
and a variety of other ways
of enhancing that welcoming
of critical feedback.
How do you see that
among your colleagues?
Do you think it
is a problem as we
consider trying to enhance
our evaluative capacity?
What would get my attention
is if the university announced
that next term when I
teach, say, Introduction
to Human Development,
there would
be faculty members
from other departments
that came to take the class
and evaluate my teaching.
That would get my attention.
I'd be really
interested to know what
a historian thought about how I
teach that introductory course.
And I think it would be
really fun for me, too.
Of course, I think that's right.
Creating a community of
teachers to talk about this.
So at the level of
the departments,
at first level, and
then beyond that,
would be really valuable
not in terms of--
talking about teaching makes
us all conscious of what
we do often frankly,
out of imitation or out
of expediency because we
run out of other ideas.
And looking to someone else
in this spirit of exchange
and trust would be fantastic.
Looking to a
professional teacher.
Yeah.
Right, so sort of normalize
imperfection in a way.
Gary, what do you think?
We should collect
all this information.
We don't know exactly
what to collect.
Having teachers in
the back of the room
would definitely
get my attention,
but how should I react
to their opinions?
Like, you said something
that sounded clear to me.
OK, that's fine.
But was it actually clear
to the freshmen in my class?
I don't know.
And that person doesn't
necessarily know the answer
to the question.
So listening to that
person's opinions
might not be the right answer.
On the other hand, they
might have useful feedback
for certain purposes.
So I just think that
there's a lot more
information we could collect.
It's becoming so much
more easier to do.
It can be used for so
many more purposes.
You know, just
think of students.
Where do they get advice
about what subjects to take?
The other students in
their entry way, right?
Well now, it's pretty easy to--
and we should--
collect the whole path
that every student takes
all the way through Harvard.
And pretty much everything
that happens to them.
And then we do that
for a little while.
And then the next person,
the next freshmen comes
into the dorm and
asks a question--
they can also ask
their friends--
but we can also give them advice
from the last 5,000 people
that have gone through Harvard.
I think it's a much more
systematic in summation.
It doesn't tell them what to
do, it just says, you know,
you've taken this course, and
then this course, and then
this course, and you've
had this experience,
you know, at that point,
there's been about 50 people
that have gone that path.
And they forked off
in two directions.
Here are those directions.
These are interesting things.
You might actually
want to know that.
So that's useful
for the students.
And there's very similar
kinds of information
we could have for faculty.
You know, if people
have a, let's
say, 50 year
teaching experience,
that's an n of 50, that's
50 observations of teaching
evaluations.
We can give them
an enormous amount
more information
than that, that they
couldn't have done in 1875.
I think it would be really
salutary in many ways, too.
And very valuable
for the Humanities
because I think we find
many maps of people
who went through Harvard
concentrated in humanities
and are now running the world.
They're not unemployed.
They're not living in
their mother's basement.
They're running the world.
And that would be
helpful, I think,
in making the case for choice,
and selection, and variety.
I do worry a little
bit about the big data
and how the
individual is still--
it just can feel like
a cog or a statistic.
And you want to preserve
the sense of themselves
as blazing their trail.
And so it would have to
be presented with care.
And also the idea
that we do, in fact,
know every time they
swept into their dorm
and where they
went, but in fact,
we don't use that information
because we want people
to be able to live the way--
I feel I lived largely
untracked in the old days.
And I just sort of
worry a little bit
about creating so much
self-consciousness.
And so there's a balance.
It can be there if you want
to know maybe, rather than--
We should do it in
a way that helps.
So yes, there's definitely
huge disadvantages.
But these are things that are
possible now that have never
been possible before.
We can use them in
really bad ways.
We ought to be able to use them
that empowers the students.
So for technology,
we always say there's
a continuum from
fully automated, which
is like a driverless car
where you don't tell it
where to go, to fully
human, where a human being,
it's no longer possible for them
to include all the information
that they have access to.
What you really want is
something in the middle.
Right.
And it's not only a balance,
really, it's computer assisted.
It's computer assisted
human lead technology.
That's really what you want.
But you want it assisted
in the right way
so that you get to lead.
If we have a whole bunch of
computers that go to school,
that's fine.
But that's not what we're after.
So we have just a
few minutes left.
So what I want to do
is ask each of you
if you could do one
thing to advance
the evaluation of teaching
at Harvard, what would be?
Not that it would be the only
thing, but the first thing.
And I'm going to
leave Gary last,
because he's going to
give us a whole research
plan that we will embark on.
So Doug, I'll start with you.
What would be one step that
you would take to improve
the evaluation of teaching?
I think I come
back to this thing
I said earlier on,
is I'd like to know
what is change students'
lives when they reflect on it
five to 10 years
after they graduate.
So not, whether they
got into graduate school
or medical school, but are
they happy with their life?
What did they learn in our
concentration, in our classes?
And what really
mattered to them?
And the trouble is, I don't
know how to ask that question.
And you could ask that
in a conversation,
but I don't know how
to ask it in a survey.
But maybe the psychology
and sociology departments
can help figure out,
how do you probe that?
Because that is, after all,
the essence of a liberal arts
education.
It's not to learn a fact
so that I can get a job,
it's to change who you are.
So it's not a very good answer.
So that's what I'd like to do,
but I don't know how to do it.
I think it's a great answer.
I agree entirely.
The conversation, actually, one
on one conversation with alum,
the long graduated student,
is the greatest gift.
You know, when a student comes
back to town and gets in touch.
And so there's nothing
that you can supplement it,
but that's a key.
Just, obviously, it's a small,
small piece of feedback.
I suppose I would be interested
in seeing more of the peer
group faculty discussion
and working with the the Bok
center, and amongst ourselves.
Maybe at the department
level to start,
because these conversations
are still pretty new, actually.
And obviously,
what HILT has done,
and these kinds of gatherings
have been really important.
So creating more sense of
shared interest in one another's
teaching.
And just for fun, going
to other people's classes.
Possibly, just for
the content, really.
And to get ideas.
I think I think
that's a really low--
you know, obviously, it
would have to be voluntary.
And it could be really rewarding
for all the people involved.
So the concept that teaching
is a form of ongoing learning.
Absolutely.
So that you have to be
vulnerable to learn.
Because it has to mean--
you don't know everything yet.
You don't have you're perfect--
what were they?
50 minute lectures in which
they are entirely balanced
and thought there wasn't
time for one thing?
Yeah.
That's great.
OK, Gary.
Drew put me last because
she knew I had no idea what
the answer to the question was.
So it gave me time to think.
So what I would suggest is--
so the-- I'm still thinking.
The most important innovation
in statistics and data science
in the last few centuries
has been separating,
as I did a minute
ago, the quantity
that we're trying to estimate
from the way of estimating it.
So I think we should
completely separate that.
Let's have a committee
and have people come up
with all of the ways that all
of the things that we would
actually like to know, separate
from how we go and estimate it.
Over time, it's
going to be easier
to estimate those things
better and better.
But let's figure
out, unconstrained
from the difficulties
of actually doing it,
what we would
actually want to know.
I think that would
be enlightening.
I think we talked about
a lot of them here.
What we do is, before that
innovation in statistics,
people would conflate the two.
They'd say, oh, we want to
know about how well teachers
are teaching.
So we'll ask the students.
We'll write a question down.
Actually, that's
a really bad way.
Writing your question
down is not a bad way,
but survey research
is really difficult.
Just, let me make
one little eddy here.
You think you can
write a question that's
really clear so a lot of other
people can understand it,
people that you don't know,
people that you really
don't know the details about
or their personal lives.
And you can do that.
We all think we
can do that, right?
We'll just write
it very clearly.
After all, we're
all writers, right?
OK.
So and you're not going to
have any misunderstandings.
But how often have you
had misunderstandings,
massive misunderstandings, with
your spouse, or your parents,
or your kids, that you've
known for 20 or 30 years?
Right?
So I that is actually
really difficult.
So not only is it
difficult to get it right
and get to get the
understanding right between two
people, a little bit like we
were talking about earlier,
but figuring out
whether that actually
estimates the thing
that we care about,
is an entirely
separate question.
So I would I would hope that
we would separate the two.
The second is a research
project, absolutely,
as you said.
But the first one is, we
might be able to set up
what our goals are.
And so let's have a
committee and focus on that.
Well, thank you.
This was an extraordinarily
rich discussion.
And I certainly learned a lot.
And I'd evaluate your
teaching, just now,
as really outstanding.
So thank you.